Aaron was asked to find if f of X is
equal to x squared minus 1 to the 2/3
power has a relative maximum this is her
solution and then they give us her steps
and at the end they say is Aaron's work
correct if not what's her mistake so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out yourself is Aaron correct
or did she make a mistake in where was
that mistake all right now let's just do
it together so she says that this is the
derivative I'm just going to reevaluate
it here to the right of her work so
let's see f prime of X is just going to
be the chain rule I'm going to take the
derivative of the outside with respect
to the inside so this is going to be 2/3
times x squared minus 1 to the 2/3 minus
1 so to the negative 1/3 power times the
derivative of the inside with respect to
X so the derivative of x squared minus 1
with respect to X is 2x there's a fire
hydrant
fi-fire fire not a hydrant that would be
a noisy hydrant there's a fire truck
outside but okay I think it's it's past
but this looks like what she got for the
derivative because if you multiply 2
times 2x you do indeed get 4x you have
this 3 right over here in the
denominator and x squared minus 1 to the
negative 1/3 that's the same thing as x
squared minus 1 to the 1/3 in the
denominator which is the same thing as a
cube root of x squared minus 1 so all of
this is looking good that is indeed the
derivative step to the critical point is
x equals 0 so let's see a critical point
is where our first derivative is either
equal to 0 or it is undefined and so it
does indeed see seen that f prime of 0
is going to be 4 times 0 is going to be
0 over 3 times the cube root of 0 minus
1 of negative 1 and so this is 3 times
negative 1 or 0 over negative 3 so this
is indeed equal to 0 so this is true a
critical point is at x equals 0 but a
question is is this the only critical
point well as we've mentioned a critical
point is where functions derivative is
either equal to 0 or it's undefined
this is the only one where the
derivative is equal to 0 but can you
find some X values where the derivative
is undefined
well what if we make the derivative what
would make the denominator of the
derivative equal to zero well if x
squared minus one is equal to zero you
take the cube root of zero you're gonna
get zero in the denominator so what
would make x squared minus one equal to
zero well X is equal to plus or minus
one these are also critical points
because they make F prime of X undefined
so I'm not feeling good about step two
it is true that a critical point is x
equals zero but it is not the only
critical point so I would put that there
and the reason why it's important you
know you might say well what's the harm
and not noticing these other critical
points she identified one maybe this is
the relative maximum point but as we
talked about in other videos in order to
use the first derivative test so to
speak and find this place where the
first derivative is zero in order to
test whether it is a maximum or a
minimum point is you have to sample
values on either side of it to make sure
that you have a change a change in sign
of the derivative but you have to make
sure that when you test on either side
that you're not going beyond another
critical point because critical points
are places where you can change
direction and so let's see what she does
in step 3 right over here well it is
indeed in step three that she's testing
she's trying to test values on either
side of the critical point that she that
the one critical point that she
identified but the problem here the
reason why this is a little shady is
this is beyond another critical point
that is less than zero and this is
beyond this is greater than another
critical point that is greater than zero
this is larger than the critical point
one and this is less than the critical
point negative one what she should have
tried is x equals zero point five and x
equals negative zero point five so this
is what she should have done is try
maybe negative two negative one negative
one half zero one half and then one we
know is undefined and then positive two
because this is a candidate critical a
candidate extremum this is a candidate
extremum and this is a candidate
extremum right over here and so you want
to see and which of these situations you
have a
sign change of the derivative and you
just want to test in the intervals
between the extremum points so I would
say that really the main mistake she
made is that step two is not identifying
all of the critical points